[Musica]
il mondo non manca di persone gentili
mela ripeto il mondo non manca di
persone gentili
è una bella frase spero non è mia questa
frase
e l'ho sentita da una signora
straordinaria meravigliosa
che me l'ha concessa in una stazione
ferroviaria molto molto lontano da qui
nell'est dell'ucraina poi poi ci
arriviamo
era bella frase
cielo forse detta da me adesso qui
vestito di lino
in quest'isola bellissima circondato da
affetto stima amore
curiosità di qualcuno di voi non ha lo
stesso peso che ha avuto quando io l'ho
ascoltata perché è molto facile da qui a
dire che il mondo non manca tensione non
è pieno di persone gentili ma immune non
manca di persone gentili e molto facile
mi rendo conto
eppure è il fulcro del mio racconto
questa frase è da quando l'ho ascoltata
è diventata un po anche la la bussola
per la mia vita futura m a e la scatola
nera di tante cose che ho vissuto in
passato
ho trascorso gli ultimi mesi in ucraina
per lavoro quando sono rientrato da poco
e le domande che mi vengono rivolte più
di frequente sono come stai
hai visto cose brutte e non ha gli
incubi la notte
e tutte domande che io accolgo con
piacere no perché poi sono una
manifestazione di affetto di interesse
nei miei confronti
però le persone quando io rispondo resta
sempre un po deluse dalle mie risposte
perché io gli dico come stai bene e la
verità sto bene
hai visto tante cose brutte sì purtroppo
ho visto tantissime cose brutte
non ha gli incubi
senti no io non ho gli incubi mi
dispiace deludere le persone me lo
chiedo ma io non ho incubi
ho una mia tecnica ma questa è un'altra
vicenda
ma se non ho avuto incubi finora dopo
questi mesi della scorso in ucraina il
merito è senza dubbio anche di questa
persona
è leonor la persona di cui vi parlavo
prima della stazione ferroviaria
la signora è leonor l'ho incontrata a
slavi unsc che è una cittadina nell'est
nel don basta una regione del donbass la
città una città all'interno di una
regione molto
complicata sulla linea del fuoco quando
ci siamo incontrati era veramente la
linea del fuoco era molto molto
pericoloso trovarsi lì è infatti tutti
scappavano
adesso arriviamo la signora eleanor ve
la faccio godere un altro po e poi dopo
vi dirò qualche giorno prima di
incontrarla mi trovavo in un'altra
stazione ferroviaria acra matos che
forse avrete sentito se seguite le news
era la stazione ferroviaria dove da
giorni si attivavano queste migliaia di
persone che cercavano di lasciare
quell'area che hamatos che a pochi
chilometri da slavia
cercavano di lasciare questa regione
perché appunto pericolosissima molto
rischiosa
dopo diversi giorni questa stazione
ferroviaria è stata centrata da un
missile
più di 50 persone sono morte
per una serie di fortunati eventi l'auto
su cui viaggiava insieme a delle altre
persone è arrivata in ritardo quel
giorno saremmo stati lì
tuttavia siamo arrivati pochi minuti
dopo quindi comunque il piazzale era
pieno di
di cadaveri e di quello che restava
anche dei corpi di persone adulte di
anziani come la signora eleonora e anche
di bambini
me lo devo dire quindi io questa è una
persona con un incrollabile fede
nell'umano vi dico che anche lì in quel
momento la mia fede ha vacillato
e poi il colpo di scena a volte succede
basta per ora per eleonora il colpo di
scena è proprio lei
in un'altra stazione quella di slavia
nascano mi dicevo era l'ultimo treno da
alivar fa l'ultimo treno per l'ovest per
al è la è ancora la zona più sicura
dell'ucraina e le persone cercavano di
scappare in tutti i modi e quel treno
era l'ultimo possibile
successivamente l'unica possibilità
erano i mezzi propri e non tutti hanno
mezzi propri non tutti hanno la benzina
per poter andarsene
quindi io incontro eleanor
le chiedo faccio un intervistano
chiacchieriamo tra le cose che le chiede
di come dove stai andando
eleonora 84 anni e affaticata perché ha
difficoltà motorie una donna anziana
e non sapeva dove stesse andando il
treno dice no non lo so forse va nel
barney l'ovest non so esattamente in che
città forse alle opoli
che coraggio questa donna e poi le
chiedo che mi guardo intorno perché non
c'era nessuna giornale le chiedo ma dove
sono le persone che ti accompagnano
comunque la donna di una certa età e
dice no no io sono da sola non c'è
nessuno con me
che coraggio questa donna
e poi le chiedo ma tu conosci qualcuno a
leopoli hai un contatto a me dice no qui
mi stand e dice no no
il mondo non manca di persone gentili ci
accoglieranno
il mio cervello esploso di fronte a
questa cosa perché vi faccio un attimo
il re cup
paese in guerra
fuori bombardavano la sirena antiaereo e
continuava a fischiare a urlare la
signora el e signora eleanor 84 anni in
col bastone era il suo unico compagno di
viaggio il bastone
non sapeva dove andare
nonostante ciò con tutte le difficoltà
d'ascola raggiunto la stazione per sale
su un treno che l'avrebbe portata chissà
dove chissà come però la signora elena
aveva una fiducia incrollabile
per gli altri
perché secondo lei il mondo non manca di
persone gentili e quindi oggi ho deciso
di parlarvi di gentilezza e di coraggio
e ho scelto queste due qualità perché mi
è capitato di incontrarle anzi più che
incontrare si sono sono apparse
netta in questi anni
in maniera veramente improbabile
inaspettata
girando per il mondo girando per la vita
soprattutto per la vita degli a delle
altre persone e io penso che sia molto
difficile
essere essere gentili ho scelto questo
tema proprio perché il tema del ted e
mediterraneo
io come forse molti di voi sono nato nel
e sono cresciuto
circondato da gente di bellezza e di
coraggio
e stata la mia educazione mediterranea
di educazione siberiana ha avuto
un'educazione mediterranea sono molto
fortunato sono riconoscente al caso per
questa per questa mia educazione
eppure io conti sono cresciuto
circondato questi gesti però io continua
a sorprendermi di tutto ciò e noi non me
lo spiego continuo a sentirmi molto
piccolo
di fronte a gesti di gentilezza di
coraggio come quello della signora
eleonora e quindi mi sono chiesto come
mai
il tema dover venire qui mi ha costretto
a riflettere su questa cosa e alla fine
ho capito
che io ho scelto questo perchè
il mediterraneo alla fine è una tragedia
mediterraneo è una tragedia
mi dispiace dirvi che il mediterraneo
è un cimitero
enorme bellissimo è un cimitero
bellissimo più bello che abbia mai visto
ed è un cimitero dove per fortuna nostra
le croci non stanno a galla e quindi ci
possiamo godere
questo cimitero bellissimo è una
tragedia perché la fauna e la flora
soffocano continuamente
ed è una tragedia perché ci sono delle
parti del mediterraneo e sono
inquinatissime da fare schifo dove
nessuno di noi vorrebbe andare per colpa
nostra
perché ci muoviamo su barche su navi che
sputano queste palle di fumo nero si
dice sempre che noi mettiamo la natura
ogni volta che vedo quest'anno si
mangiano le seppie le sette spruzzano il
nero per difendersi dai predatori e
invece abbiamo queste navi e siamo i
predatori di noi stessi perché i
processi stiamo avvelenando quindi il
collegamento in realtà è dettato dal
fatto che sono molto deluso dal dalla
gente del mediterraneo come me che è
cresciuta come me con l'educazione
mediterranea sono molto deluso
moltissimo
a questo punto io vorrei fare una
domanda e poi dopo quando finirà spero
veramente di incontrare sconosciuti tra
voi che mi daranno la risposta secondo
voi
per avere una bella vita una buona vita
piena
serve più gentilezza o più coraggio
pensateci io non ce l'ho la risposta
quindi non c'è una slide che ve lo dirà
non lo so però io in tutti questi anni
ho capito ma ho visto ho visto l'ho
vista questa cosa ho visto che per
essere ci vuole molto coraggio per
essere gentili
molto coraggio e le persone gentili sono
molto coraggiose perché ci vuole molto
coraggio per essere gentili in questo
mondo e in questo tempo tantissimo
tantissimo e quindi io vi invito come
invito me stesso
ad essere gentili ad essere gentili
ad avere coraggio nell'essere gentili ad
essere gentili con gli altri
ad essere gentili
soprattutto si anche con gli altri e che
vedete quando c'è il coraggio
a tragedia svanisce
svanisce perché diventa altro si eleva
diventa speranza della speranza non è
una parola che adesso vi sto dicendo sul
palco bella che ti riempie la speranza è
veramente un elemento
materiale potrebbe essere quasi un
elemento chimico nella tavola periodica
esiste la speranza ho visto gente che
non poteva che non poteva camminare come
la chanel e onora che ce l'ha fatta è
rimasta in piedi ecco girone a camminare
spinta dalla speranza di poter andare
via così come ho visto gente non
annegare
perché spinta dalla speranza della riva
ce l'hanno fatta perché la speranza è
qualcosa di reale di concreto
e quindi io vi rinnovo l'invito ad
essere gentili e coraggiose essere
gentili con gli altri gli enti di col
mediterraneo
e di sforzarvi di essere sempre in
quella parte del mondo che non manca di
persone gentili e che in questo modo
forse
il mediterraneo non sarà prima tragedia
è soprattutto non delude rete la signora
eleonora direi che è il massimo
ma cosa volete quando mi sono guardata
da automatico
berruto
9 si è scontata
nel ribes gordini prima
[Applauso]